[MUSIC]
>> My name is Deb Gruenfeld and
I'm a faculty member at Stanford in
the Graduate School of Business.
One of my favorite classes is
called managing groups and teams.
And I'm going to share five key
takeaways from that class today.
>> [MUSIC]
There's no one way to design teams for
success.
You have to start with the end in mind.
Often, when we talk about building a team,
we think of people first,
who do I like to work with and
how can I get as many stars as possible?
But we believe you can't
know who to work with or
how to structure your team until you know
what's needed for the team to succeed.
Teams should be designed around the clear,
engaging direction, a goal.
So the building of the team is dictated,
by the specific outcomes we hope to reach.
>> [MUSIC]
>> When making choices about how to
design teams for different purposes,
there are two key
dimensions to choose from.
The first is that you have to
decide what to do about diversity.
That is, what to maximize diversity
to prioritize learning outcomes and
sharing different perspectives and
inclusion.
Or do you want to control for
the effects of diversity by making
sure team members goals are aligned.
And an agreement can be reached
to the team to move forward?
The second big question,
in addition to what to do about
diversity is what to do about hierarchy.
Whether to make sure participation and
influence are even.
Or to make sure that the voices of
experts or key stakeholders are more
influential than the voices of
people who are more competent.
Those opinions shouldn't matter as much.
Your choices will depend again, on what's
necessary for the team to succeed.
>> [MUSIC]
>> It's not enough to compose teams
with people who create the appearance of
surface level diversity and assume that
our team will take care of itself.
Unless you take steps to ensure that
the deeper level diverse perspectives and
experiences and knowledge that
you're seeking actually surface and
receive attention.
There's a good chance that they won't.
So it's important to use
processes in general,
that normalize,
raising alternative points of view,
asking questions and
challenging others assumptions.
These things don't tend to
happen on their own in teams,
especially in diverse groups where levels
of psychological safety might be loved.
>> [MUSIC]
>> Expertise rarely predicts
influence in teams,
while things like physical attractiveness
and gender predict influence very well.
In part this is because
teens fear of conflict and
are motivated to reach agreement
as quickly as possible.
It's important to be aware
of these dynamics, so
that we can all individually
take steps to counteract them.
It's good to have ways of
drawing out quieter members and
gently quieting others,
to create space for
less hierarchical,
more equal participation
>> [MUSIC]
>> Many people think it's always
better to bring a more participants in
collaborative, empowering hands-off
approach to leading teams.
But in reality, managing or leading
a team is a delicate balancing act,
between imposing enough
top down structure and
control while inviting enough
bottom up participation.
Imposing direction and structure can
feel oppressive or paternalistic.
But failing to articulate and
reinforce a clear vision of success
can leave team members feeling lost and
unmotivated.
The takeaway here is that it's
not a leaders job to manage
teammates feelings or
be as likeable as possible.
The job is to manage the team's
performance and outcomes in a way that
engages stretches and develops the team
and guides them forward to success.
>> [MUSIC]
>> I was not a serious
student in high school.
I mostly was interested in boys and
going to parties with my friends.
So I think it has come actually as
quite a shock to many of the people who
Knew me when I was younger that
that I'm a professor, yeah.